okay um
i'm gonna call the next play because we
talked about this covey craziness so i'm
gonna try to recap today just today
just today all right this is the nfl's
new normal all right so
the jets that's where i was scoring guys
thank you uh presumptive positive
so the cardinals who are traveling east
to plato jets
are
they're basically their game is tbd
because the jets all got sent home
because of presumptive positives so
everybody go home that's the jets
yeah
tennessee
is b is playing buffalo
tuesday
two tuesdays
somebody said tuesday okay
uh
assuming that they have no new positive
tests
okay because
today first time in a while no positive
tests um after 22 tested positive in
that organization
patriots
they got
the broncos monday
5 00 p.m easter
nice okay 5 p.m easter
the patriots and broncos look at that
exactly right right we're perfect lead
in okay
um and am i missing anybody else oh
uh now the thursday night game
from that was supposed to be bill's
chiefs is now
yeah exactly that's now sunday i mean
that's this is this is very 2020. i mean
so none of us have a routine anymore you
know none of us can make plans anymore
this entire season is tbd
people always like to throw around hey
we're all day to day yeah exactly that's
exactly what we are right now it's all
day to day not only are we flying the
plane while we build it we are just all
on standby right now like this is the
nfl's new normal get used to it
like the idea of of of having
you know normal weeks and rests and and
and a routine no these creatures a habit
they they got we all got to learn
something new now i mean we're going to
have short weeks
short notice even
and if you're the nfl
there's there's a there's a bright spot
there's a silver lining to this chaos
because i don't know are they missing
all right not only are they that
thursday night well i'm saying it from
this standpoint not only are they
missing this thursday night uh whatever
it's going to be whether it's a joe
biden town hall or
debate whatever it was going to be not
only does the thursday night chiefs
bills game
now avoid going head-to-head with that
or conflicting with that into sunday
we talked about it before i don't know
what the ratings were but
cbs
lost patriots chiefs on sunday but they
got it on monday
and now bill's titans is on track for
tuesday
you know tentatively
tuesday
i mean
they've all they've already owned one
day of the week
i mean pretty soon we're gonna be
getting nfl football seven days a week
before the year is out there's going to
be a wednesday game there's going to be
a friday game there's going to be we
already there's already been saturday
games saturday specials late in the year
there's going to be weeks where games
are going to be scattered throughout all
seven days of the week because if they
want to get this thing in
not to mention we already know that
playoff teams are going to be by winning
percentage there's going to be
imbalanced schedules
there's some teams going to play more
games than others welcome to our new nfl
normal
you know it mike it's a good point on
just making uh making the best of a bad
situation and it's not your original
plan but the plan as you look at it
well it's not so bad you know tuesday
night football it might be wednesday
night football and i think eventually
mike smith they're going to have to
get some alternative sites in place
right now and they don't have to be sexy
we know that because some some people
don't have people in the stands now
kansas city they have 16 000 in the
stands miami's going to have his 13 000
in the stands but some people have
five people 20.
so i think when things start to break
down like like patriots chiefs and your
concerns about traveling i think that
each nfl team should have like you have
your alternate jerseys you should have
some alternate sites in your region just
in case
just in case
stuff happens you know what i'm saying
but that's one here's the other thing
just like the rest of us think about
there were some businesses
who said hey we are we are a dining in
business then covet hit
and if you want to stay in business you
better get your takeout game out there
and people get less delivery
you know right pull up
bring it to your car yeah zoom how about
zoom zoom was like the domain of the
academy
for years and years and all of a sudden
learning from home working from home
everybody's talking about zoom
and uh
am i the holster you want me to make you
the host that kind of stuff but
i think there are two different
categories okay that's the rosie stuff
that's the rosy stuff mike smith but
here's the stuff that we really got to
talk about
there's the
unintended positive silver lining of
this thing that's one side and then on
the other side
there are the tennessee titans and i
don't know if you heard mike florio kind
of floating out some possibilities what
he's hearing about fines what the fines
could be
as high as a fine as high as 10 million
dollars
loss of a first round pick loss of a
first round pick the suspension of not
just mike brabel the head coach but john
robinson the general manager
so drop that yeah i know stuff i know
stuff just happens with covid so there
are two different categories hey it just
happened i wasn't doing anything wrong
it just happened then there's tennessee
which it when you recognize the
investments
we're going to find out yeah brazen
disregard no absolutely man i mean it's
like and that's the that's
you know
it's going to be confusing enough it's
going to be
bizarre enough we don't need your help
says roger goodell says says the nfl
it's like this is hard enough as it is
we've done all we can to put protocols
in place a lot of people call in for 32
bubbles but we've done all we can to put
protocols in place to mitigate the
spread of this disease we're not we
can't prevent positive tests we're just
trying to prevent it from being too too
bad but when we tell you to go home go
home
don't stage unauthorized workouts when
you tell you to wear a mask wear masks
it's not optional i saw today where
officials can penalize coaches massless
coaches who approach them in games to
yell at him you get so game-changing
penalties
can result from your disregard for the
rules when it comes to wearing mass on
the sidelines it's it's incredible but
it's where we are it's where we are and
these old old habits die hard and these
are these are the ultimate creatures of
habit coaches pro football players
who've done some certain things their
whole lives like
the office the great untold story is
like i would love to know the effect
right now on chemistry and communication
where we're talking you talked about
zoom
in distance meetings distance learning
is not just for me and you with our kids
these teams have undergone distance
learning in the off season virtual
meetings what the hell does that look
like you know
this is not how they're used to training
yeah and you know everybody's got to
have their video up too none of this uh
you know
right do it you gotta pay attention and
michael it's on a dime it's like one day
you're at work
and then the next day hey everybody go
home
like wow how does that work so so you're
so this is this is the you know
wednesday thursday this is the heart of
the practice week the meeting week and
now you're just sending people home just
like that i'd love to know if there's a
way to quantify
uh what kind of effect that has on the
preparation and therefore the outcome of
games we talked we saw it monday day of
games two plane travel to kansas city
yeah with your backup quarterback
because on on saturday
you found out that your starting
quarterback cam newton had tested
positive you send everybody home
everybody's on standby until monday when
you're flying two planes
this is bizarre and i and i think it's
become we're so accustomed in the real
world
to
figuring that figuring it out and not
being able to rely on routine or rely on
anything
so i don't i don't know that we fully
grasp how difficult this is for the nfl
in particular to be trying to do this
right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports